bientôt midi david et youssef met la
table
ces deux mineurs sorti de détention ont
été placés sur décision du juge dans
l'unité hébergement diversifié renforcé
de voisins-le-bretonneux encore monter
dans ma chambre je chante ici s'est pas
rangé leurs s'est arrangé la casse comme
on dit justement youssef lui à 15 ans de
nationalité marocaine il vient de sortir
de détention
il est arrivé le 7 novembre dernier dans
l'établissement de papel pour recherche
travail j'ai fermé qu'elle aimait tender
wedge ces deux jeunes préparent leur
repas un atelier cuisine menée par un
éducateur et une cuisinière au menu
poisson pané et salades crudités
retrouvent à la cuisson et on retourne
d'accord cet établissement spécialisé
dans la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse accueille des jeunes de 13 à 21
ans
plusieurs modalités de prise en charge
l'hébergement résidence éducative des
résidant en appartement partagé ou des
jeunes en famille d'accueil
accueillant journée sur le site objectif
l'accompagnement à la réinsertion
sociale et professionnelle
cet établissement la correspond plus aux
nouvelles orientations de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse qui souhaite
que nous arrivions à différents dieux
pardon diversifier les modalités de
prise en charge afin de pouvoir proposer
des
d accueil qui se rapproche le plus des
besoins des besoins des jeunes
actuellement dix jeunes sont placés dans
l'unité d'hébergement quatre ans
résidence éducative dont david et
youssef à terme une vingtaine de
résidants devraient occuper cette unité